after eight seasons and ten years on the
air
game of thrones came to a surprising and
controversial end we're here to rank its
major characters endings from
worst to best and boy there are some
doozies
introduced in the third season as a
slave missandei is quickly welcomed into
daenerys targaryen's camp as a free
woman
the two soon become close friends and
confidants
rarely leaving each other's side
throughout much of the series
however in the show's final season when
daenerys's ships are attacked
missandei is captured by the allied
forces of euron greyjoy
and cersei lannister when daenerys tries
to save her friend
the duo beheads miss sandy in front of
the desperate dragon queen
miss sandy's death is tragic and her
last word proves her loyalty to daenerys
with
gutting finality
[Music]
although missandei using daenerys's
catchphrase was powerful
her death was in poor taste one of the
show's few characters of color
missandei was a thoughtful layered
character who was
needlessly killed off simply to motivate
daenerys in the show's final episodes
one of the show's most sinister villains
cersei lannister looms large over game
of thrones
from her affair with her twin brother
jaime to her abject cruelty towards her
enemies
one would think that a complex character
like cersei would get an ending
befitting her impressive legacy
but unfortunately that doesn't come to
pass
in the final season cersei ends up in
the line of fire when daenerys arrives
at king's landing
dragon blazing as cersei's home base
collapses in rubble
the typically inscrutable queen is alone
until her brother jamie arrives
the two die together crushed under
falling debris as they attempt to escape
this ending proved to be pretty
disappointing for fans who expected the
ruthless queen to go out in a more
dramatic
fashion over the course of the series
jamie lannister becomes one of the
show's most complex characters
after beginning the series loyal to
cersei jaime eventually turns away from
his sister
deciding to help his brother tyrion and
daenerys
instead but at the end of the series
jamie
returns to cersei right after finally
consummating his slow burn relationship
with brienne of tarth
ultimately jaime rejects his honorable
path to die alongside cersei in the red
keep though it makes poetic sense that
the duo would leave the world together
it felt as though jaime's anticlimactic
ending
undermined many seasons of impressive
character growth
as one of the most popular and beloved
characters on the small screen
many fans fully expected daenerys the
mother of dragons
to take the iron throne by the end of
the series
unfortunately daenerys had a far
different fate
waiting for her upon conquering king's
landing
daenerys loses control of her emotions
and
lays waste to the city killing countless
innocent civilians
even her closest allies realize she must
be stopped
before she can take the iron throne
daenerys's lover jon snow
kills his queen for the good of the
realm in the wake of her death
her last remaining dragon drogon torches
the throne
and carries his mother away daenerys's
ending is certainly
dramatic but her sudden descent into
madness and
rush death tarnish her character's
otherwise incredible story
from the very first scene of game of
thrones viewers are made aware that
despite rampant infighting within the
seven kingdoms
the realm has a bigger threat looming
the ancient and mysterious
beings known as white walkers though the
night's watch guards the northern wall
to try and protect
westeros from what lies beyond the white
walkers start heading south in the
show's second season
when the show's heroes finally face off
against the night king in his army
all hope seems lost however just when
the humans have all but given up
arya stark leaps from the darkness and
kills the night king
once and for all while this makes for an
epic moment
it's also weirdly disappointing after
years of mystery surrounding the night
king his entire storyline
ends in seconds the night king was set
up as a major villain
but ultimately the show disposes of him
like a minor baddie
it's hard not to feel cheated out of a
potentially gripping story about this
intriguing character
few of game of thrones conniving
characters had as much potential as
marjorie tyrell
an unparalleled strategist who was also
the prize beauty of the wealthy house
tyrell
after a short-lived marriage to renly
baratheon
marjorie shifts her allegiances to the
lannister family in king's landing
before long marjorie is married to the
sadistic
joffrey baratheon but when he is
assassinated at their wedding
she ends up serving as queen to his
sweet younger brother
tommen unfortunately for marjorie
however
she makes an enemy of cersei almost
immediately thanks to her beauty
and quick mind when cersei vindictively
blows up the sept of balor
before she can be tried for various
crimes
marjorie is among her many victims
although marjorie realizes what's
happening before cersei's plan is
executed
she's unable to escape in time bringing
her
fascinating story to an abrupt and
disappointing conclusion
after being paralyzed by jamie lannister
in the show's first episode
bran stark gradually grows into someone
entirely new
taking on the mantle of the omniscient
three-eyed raven
when westeros needs to choose a new king
in the wake of daenerys death
tyrion makes a surprising case for bran
to take the throne
despite previous assertions from bran
that he has no political ambitions for
himself
i can never be lord of anything and the
three-eyed raven
bran is somehow chosen as the next king
of westeros
the reasons that put him on the throne
are nonsensical at best
bringing the series long struggle for
the iron throne to a
frustrating and unsatisfying conclusion
a master of gossip and intrigue varys
spends the series frequently teaming up
with fellow strategists
like peter littlefinger baelish and
tyrion
to advance his political career and the
cause of peace in westeros
for most of the show there is rarely any
doubt that varys
always has a brilliant plan up his
sleeve unfortunately
varys potential is wildly squandered by
the time the show draws to a close
after doing very little in the last two
seasons
he acts completely out of character when
he stages an open
obvious coup against daenerys
unsurprisingly his scheme is uncovered
and daenerys executes him for treason
resulting in an utterly unsatisfying
ending for one of the show's most
intriguing characters
introduced as a perpetually frightened
brother of the night's watch
samwell tarly eventually proves himself
in battle
and spends time explaining his knowledge
at the citadel
though sam finds himself rejected by his
noble family
his growth as a character is pretty
impressive
at the conclusion of game of thrones sam
is shown wearing maester's robes
indicating he is now one of the
intellectual elite
it turns out he has been named the grand
maester for king bran
he also writes a book that chronicles
the dramatic events of the series
and settles down with gilly and sam jr
their young son sam's ending might be
unusually neat and tidy for game of
thrones
but he deserves a happy ending theon
greyjoy begins game of thrones as the
insecure
ward of the stark family who overtakes
winterfell the second the family departs
however theon ends up suffering for his
crimes
when he's captured by the bolton clan
and tortured by
roose bolton's sadistic son ramsay
before long theon has lost his grasp on
his former identity
referring to himself only as reek
reek endures horrific torture but
eventually
theon's bravery returns as does his
loyalty to the stark family
after helping sansa stark escape
ramsay's captivity
theon volunteers to personally guard
bran during the battle of winterfell
ultimately theon sacrifices himself to
save bran
providing redemption for one of the
show's most complicated
and long-suffering characters from the
beginning
it's clear that jorah mormont harbors
romantic feelings for daenerys the young
mother of dragons
after meeting daenerys at her wedding to
dothraki warrior khal drogo
the disgraced heir of the mormont clan
pledges his loyalty to his khaleesi
and stands by your side until the bitter
end
during the battle of winterfell jorah
tries his best to defend his khaleesi
and gets mortally wounded in the process
not only does jorah nobly sacrifice
himself for his queen
but he escapes having to see daenerys
abandon her principles during her attack
on king's landing
in a way this gives jorah the best
ending he could hope for
sandor the hound clegane became a fan
favorite early on
thanks to his gruff demeanor fighting
prowess and secret
sensitive side his scarred face is
courtesy of his brother
gregor the mountain clegane who shoved
sandor into a fire when they were both
young
the hound doesn't care about much but he
does care about getting revenge on his
brother
eventually the hound forms a close bond
with arya stark
as one of his final acts he saves her
life by
convincing her to flee a crumbling
king's landing
but rather than escape with her the
hound faces off against his brother
who has become an unstoppable killing
machine
ultimately the cleganes die together
when the hound flings them both into the
flames below
giving him a tragic but poetically
fitting ending
a fighter of uncommon skill dedication
and honor brienne of tarth's refusal to
adhere to traditional gender roles
often makes her feel like an outsider
desperate to prove her worth in battle
she eventually allies herself with the
stork family
promising to protect sansa and arya as
well as she can
along the way brienne also forms an
intense bond with jamie lannister
he knights brienne before the battle of
winterfell
making her the first female knight of
the seven kingdoms
when they both survive the attack jaime
and brienne
consummate their relationship
unfortunately jaime ends up abandoning
brienne for
cersei shortly thereafter though brienne
is left bereft
the blow is softened when she becomes
lord commander of the king's guard
fulfilling her destiny as one of
westeros's most
formidable and honorable warriors
serving as the stark family's servant
the lovable giant hodor
manages to find emotional nuances with
each repetition of his name
which is the only word he is able to say
for a long time viewers have no idea why
hodor has such a limited vocabulary
until season six is the door reveals his
shocking backstory
as bran gains the knowledge to become
the three-eyed raven
who can travel throughout space and time
he encounters a young hodor
who has a full vocabulary however
while bran is in the past whites attack
the present-day bran
and hodor hodor blocks the whites behind
a door so bran can escape
while in the past a young hodor yells
one sentence over and over
until it turns into a single word
[Music]
losing hodor is heartbreaking but the
revelation of his past
is an incredible feat of storytelling
while violent charming wildling tormund
giantsbane was initially no big fan of
jon snow
the two eventually become close friends
fighting alongside one another time and
time again
tormund ends up surviving the battle
against the white walkers as well as the
siege of king's landing
though his enormous crush on brienne
remains unrequited
tormund's ending is fitting with him
returning to the far north where he
belongs
alongside his sworn brother jon snow
one of game of thrones most emotionally
conflicted characters
jon snow always wants to do what's right
that instinct leaves him with a hard
decision to make when his lover
daenerys decimates the city of king's
landing
after talking to tyrion john realizes he
must do the right thing
despite his love for daenerys as the
dragon queen
reaches the iron throne she has fought
so hard to win
jon stabs her in the chest after dany's
death
drogon burns the throne and carries
danny away
but jon still must face justice for his
crime
eventually it's decided that jon will be
banished from westeros
and return to the north though this is
painted as punishment
it feels natural for jon snow who never
felt at home in the halls of the kings
and queens of westeros
he heads back into the northern
wilderness with tormund
and his loyal direwolf ghost by his side
born without a prestigious name peter
baelish
quickly learned to do anything to gain
power
eventually the conniving noble known as
littlefinger became a major player
within king's landing
running a brothel and collecting
information on the biggest names in
westeros
though he seemed loyal to sansa stark he
readily traded her to ramsay bolton when
he thought it might gain him power
once sansa returns to winterfell
littlefinger does his
very best to pit's sister against sister
attempting to turn sansa and arya
against one another
though littlefinger thinks victory is
nigh when sansa calls for a trial that
he assumes is for arya
she beats him at his own game you stand
accused of treason
how do you answer these charges
lord baelish on sansa's orders arya
slits his throat
and littlefinger's death provides an
incredibly satisfying ending for this
often despicable man for a show with its
fair share of bad guys
fewer as repulsive as ramsay bolton in
addition to tormenting theon
ramsay repeatedly assaulted sansa stark
and killed her younger brother rickon
just for fun
after he kills rickon ramsay loses the
battle of the bastards and finds himself
at the mercy of the surviving starks
bound and helpless in the depths of
winterfell
ramsay sneers at sansa until he realizes
that he's surrounded by his own snarling
dogs
when ramsay says they'll never hurt him
sansa points out that ramsay stopped
feeding them
days prior in anticipation of winning
the battle
he'd been planning to feed the starks to
his pets
as he'd done with other victims in the
past as sansa leaves him to the same
fate he dealt out to so many others
ramsay's dogs rip him to shreds putting
an end to game of thrones most
reprehensible sociopath
tyrion lannister goes on a winding
journey throughout game of thrones
but ends up right where he should be
after facing imprisonment for turning on
daenerys after her siege of king's
landing
tyrion convinces jon to assassinate
daenerys for the good of the realm
despite her allies being furious with
him tyrion is still brought to the
council that will decide the fate of
westeros's monarchy
and actually ends up hand-picking the
new king
bran chooses tyrion to serve as hand of
the king
a job he doesn't initially want after
having served his hand before
but the truth is that pulling the
strings behind a leader is where
tyrion's strengths can best be utilized
the last scene of the series sees tyrion
comfortably leading one of bran's small
council meetings
proving that he's exactly where he
belongs
after using the faceless assassin skills
that she acquired throughout the series
to seek revenge against her enemies and
defeat the night king
arya stark deserves a break
but with the wars in westeros drawing to
a close
and demand dwindling for her hard-won
fighting skills
arya is faced with the daunting decision
about what to do
with the rest of her life ultimately
arya sets off to explore the world
telling her brothers and sister that she
wants to find what's west of westeros
armed with her trusty sword needle arya
sets sail to explore the darkest corners
of the world
seeking independence outside the
contentious borders of the seven
kingdoms
arya was always a character who sought
her own path in life
so to see her continuing to challenge
herself and push boundaries
is a rewarding ending for this beloved
character
one of the overarching messages of game
of thrones always seemed to be that the
ideal leader of the seven kingdoms
would have the cunning strategy of
cersei with the honor and
trustworthiness of jon snow
so it was surprising and a little bit
frustrating when
sansa stark the character who most
embodies both qualities
is overlooked in favor of her brother
bran
however when bran becomes king the
shrewd sansa seizes that opportunity to
make an important request
the north will remain an independent
kingdom
as it was for thousands of years bran
agrees
and sansa is rewarded for her efforts
in one of the very last shots of the
series viewers watch as sansa is crowned
the queen in the north
ensuring that a stark will remain in
winterfell for years to come
though she would undoubtedly have been a
fair and capable ruler of
westeros her home in the north is where
she truly
wants to be which makes her ending the
perfect conclusion to her impressive
tale
olenna tyrell the matriarch of the
wealthy house tyrell who carries the
title of queen of thorns
is known for always being several steps
ahead of everyone else
a razor wit and even sharper tongue
serve her well
throughout the series and her final
moments are no exception
after allying herself with daenerys and
her forces
olena finds herself outmatched against
the lannister armies as they
approach her home of highgarden leaving
her trapped
unwilling to violently slay an old woman
jaime gives her a poisoned glass of wine
instead
but olenna has one last trick up her
sleeve
after drinking the poison olenna finally
reveals to jaime that she is responsible
for the death of his son with cersei
the illegitimate king joffrey tell sassy
i wanted to know it was me even though
jaime technically gets what he wants by
taking out one of his biggest enemies
olenna still manages to come out on top
giving her the best ending in all of
game of thrones
as show runner dan weiss once put it she
beats him in the middle of her own death
scene
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one